[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome happy thursday
good morning to you all
welcome to tony michael's podcast we're
gonna go through the [ __ ] list roundup
today
we got several announcements to make
[Music]
several announcements to make we're
gonna have
see see i gotta get used to this this
new format thing i'm still working on it
forgive me forgive me
uh we're still we're still working here
you guys like the new art you like the
new little uh the the thing down at the
bottom with the with the words on it and
all that kind of good stuff yeah
we're getting fancy here um you know
gabe gabe has been working hard to make
make it look a lot better and it is it
looks a lot better i really like the new
little banner that we have so if you're
if you're watching on youtube or if
you're not watching on youtube go go
check it out um and and see subscribe to
the youtube channel and you can see the
new banners and everything that's going
to be coming
um and maybe maybe just comment and pick
out the differences you know like oh
you got that wrong oh you got that right
you got that wrong so we're trying to
work we're trying to get some more
commercials in we're trying to do all
this stuff
you know to entertain you and talk about
politics all at the same time but we
have some big news today you know that
we do this show every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central now for two full
hours every single weekday
and on friday we do bonehead of the week
you guys like bonehead of the week we
used to do it on the weekends but now we
do it on fridays there's the poll the
poll is up um you can go follow us at
tonymichaelspod on twitter also follow
me and gabe on twitter as well
but the poll is up it's active uh i
don't want to give the game away but the
former guy is winning in the poll
he
this is the first time
that that the cheeto dust mobster has
appeared on the bonehead pole
like this is the very first time that
he's appeared on the bonehead pole you
know he he's like always a bonehead
a king of boneheads so he doesn't really
need to have any kind of congratulations
but we figured this week since he was
inciting violence
uh by promising the january six
insurrectionist pardons
that we would go ahead and
[Laughter]
give him his due and it looks like he he
may win um i don't know that you could
put him on a boneheaded
bonehead of the of the weak list
as a candidate and him not win and you
know i think it's like a like a [ __ ]
chewing it's like a guarantee
speaking of the january 6
insurrectionist and promising pardons
from the cheeto dust mobster i don't
know do you guys hear the news of stuart
rhodes the founder of the oath keepers
apparently uh they are not going to let
him be detained in texas
close to his quote-unquote home
and uh he apparently also
testified to the january six select
committee for six [ __ ] hours
six hours that's i mean you know
i guess i guess if you had no
information or little information about
you know like a like a conspiracy to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states you would probably have at least
six hours like if you just knew a little
bit you know just a little bit about
that conspiracy you might you might
testify for you know
eight hours six hours
someone who knew little about it
definitely
oh this is that i i wonder i wonder if
they're buying stock and depends down at
mar-a-lago
they have to be they got to be trucking
in all kinds of diapers i mean
they're [ __ ] changing diapers down at
mar-a-lago like it's going out of style
jesus [ __ ] christ this guy's got to
be [ __ ] his [ __ ] britches
and stuart rhodes the leader of the oath
keeper who is charged with seditious
conspiracy
testifies before the january 6th select
committee which donald trump is
completely [ __ ] terrified of because
he can't stop talking about it
he's [ __ ] all right let's get to some
good mornings good morning good morning
robin
elia says hi guys
well let's see
yoda says the banner is great beautiful
tony don't thank me don't thank me it
has you know it's got the name on it and
everything but
it's 100 gabe he's redeeming himself for
the executive producer you know somebody
you know he you know every once in a
while these executive producers you know
what i'm saying i think he's
i think gabe's going to join us today
you guys you guys love gabe
so i think he'll be on today at some
point uh speaking of announcements and
stuart rhodes
i don't know if you guys know this but
tomorrow tomorrow morning during the
first hour of the show we're gonna do
bonehead the second hour of the show but
the first hour of the show
we are actually going to um be doing an
interview with someone who knows a
couple people who knows stuart rhodes
the founder of the oath keepers the one
who is indicted
on on a conspiracy to overturn the
constitution united states in a
seditious way
hmm
his ex his ex-wife
tasha adams and his son dakota adams
is going to be on the show tomorrow in
the first hour
um and and i think today while we're on
air we'll probably have a little bit of
a clip again and some new some more news
about that situation with the interview
so don't miss tomorrow's show i already
have the link up on youtube um it's
already there because i feel like this
is important uh show so go over if
you're on youtube right now click the
bell notification go over and set
yourself a reminder for tomorrow's show
it's episode number 69
today's 68 tomorrow 69.
i'm not planning that out i promise
that was not planned
well you know shart is trending on
twitter this morning and so i made a
joke so i feel like this this gutter
joke stuff is probably going to be a a
thing today i'm in the i'm in the chart
in the sharp mode so we might make some
gutter jokes uh anyways tomorrow episode
number 69
is tasha dakota adams the ex-wife and
son of stuart rhodes
and not only do they tell us what they
think some of the motivations were um
for his actions on january 6 but he al
they also they also describe the eye
patch story and him shooting himself in
the face
um which is the thing that everyone
wants to know because
the way they tell it everyone's getting
it wrong the thing the story that's out
there in the media it's [ __ ] wrong
it's not right that's not how it
happened it it's not you got to come
watch how the [ __ ] eye patch became
and how he lost his eye when he shot
himself in the face
because it it is a very interesting
interesting story not only him shooting
himself in the face but also the story
behind the eye patch itself
so come come tomorrow morning and watch
live
we'll air the interview with tasha
and dakota adams stewart rhodes ex-wife
and son
tomorrow morning in the first hour first
up
so
let's get to
the [ __ ] list roundup here
i think i think that's what we should do
is do the [ __ ] list roundup because
there's a lot of stuff to um
to round up today if if you're not aware
there's all kinds of stuff going on big
news um is that president biden ordered
the um killing of the i uh leader of
isis this morning so a lot of people are
talking about that in particular
uh the isis the isis leader is dead um
of course it's bringing up the words bin
laden and other things
so
that is big news we also have susan
sarandon
um and
jesus
jenny mccarthy in the news that's the
last thing i want to talk about but it
looks like we're going to have to delete
facebook is trending um we have rudy
giuliani as a masked singer um and then
the national prayer breakfast is today
which is wholly appropriate after
after the president
executes the leader of isis let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining for the shitless
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
of today
every single day there's a huge list of
[ __ ] everywhere um don't forget to go
follow us on twitter at toni michael's
pod follow me and gabe as well
keep up with all the [ __ ] list over
there
let's uh let's go to a timeline here
oh that's not what we want
my mouse is not working where the [ __ ]
okay let's see
of course
midas has uh
mike pompeo the world is safer today
because isis leader
whatever the hell that name is is dead
they're dead
uh midas says
thank you president biden see that
wasn't so hard it wasn't so hard to say
thank you wasn't you piece of [ __ ]
okay
[Music]
let's see
oh oh here's here's here's the here's
the thing uh let's let's make this
bigger so you can see yeah there we go
um shart was trending i think it's the
wor worldly worldly is that a world
wardrobe wordle is that what it is i
don't know i don't spell worth a [ __ ] so
i couldn't play that game even though i
wanted to
yeah if i put my [ __ ] results up you
people would make fun of me so i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna play the [ __ ]
game
but shart is trending because of wordle
is that the i think that's the name of
the game shart is trending and i give
just a little bit of a [ __ ] that's the
joke i made this morning i'm sorry
i'm sorry mine's in the gutter okay um
we're going to come back to this later
there was a book burning from uh the
pastor greg locke that [ __ ] uh when gabe
comes on i think we're going to talk
about this gabe wants to talk about this
um we've been talking about
banning books and burning books you know
it's not nazi [ __ ] at all not at all not
at all now now the let's go brandon
nazis
yeah okay uh let's see here is um some
breaking news from occupy democrats
breaking january 6 committee member adam
schiff
announces that trump's offer to pardon
his insurrection is very important
evidence
that may be used in a criminal trial to
prove trump's intent
to incite violence on the january 6th on
january 6. of course of course we know
this
we know this
and we know we know we've heard the
story and i keep repeating it over and
over again in the rolling stone where
members of congress
it's been assumed
that they had a hand in making sure that
people who were trying to commit
sedition
are you following sedition who else who
who do we know who has been charged with
conspiracy to commit sedition
we know that members of congress may
have been involved in trying to make
sure to broker a deal with anyone who
would who would like to commit treason
that if they overthrew the government
and donald trump would remain king that
they would be pardoned
we know this
i wonder how far that conspiracy reaches
hmm follow the [ __ ] bouncing ball
would you okay
oh yeah michael flynn
michael flynn is a trader brad says here
you guys know um i'm bad brad berkwit is
a
veteran
secretary of defense why hasn't mike
flynn been called back to active duty
and tried for treason u.s veterans who
defended america during war and peace
want to know lock him up
absolutely
um you've seen that [ __ ] defending
vladimir putin again uh on a video which
will probably get to that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] traitor
what why in the [ __ ] and i let me go
down to the tweet here let me go down to
the tweet because it all it all [ __ ]
stems back to this stupid [ __ ]
i said biden orders kill of isis leader
gqp scrambles
for their pro-isis message to own the
libs
why does it seem like they're defending
our enemies that they're on the side of
our enemies does it [ __ ] feel like
that
does it feel like that because they
really are putin's puppies
they're really spreading the russian
propaganda putin's propaganda here
they're really on his side ron johnson
[ __ ] lindsey graham
mike flynn josh holly
come on
it really is it really is
it really is a [ __ ] obvious
um
here here you go i think this is the
only time i'm gonna mention jenny
mccarthy's name today
let's go brandon nazis love the [ __ ] lib
in quotes jenny mccarthy end of tweet
how in the how the [ __ ] did we get here
how the [ __ ] did we get here were these
maga [ __ ] i think jenny mccarthy is
some kind of [ __ ]
conservative savior or some [ __ ]
just because she's been a stupid
anti-vaxxer for [ __ ] years that's why
get out get the [ __ ] out of here
um
i also tweeted i was on a tweet storm
this morning i don't know if you guys
know this [ __ ] mike fl oh [ __ ] [ __ ] mike
playing arrest that [ __ ] pretty
simple
pretty simple stuff
one of our favorite here mike flynn is
hell-bent on destroying america well
yeah he wants a fascist state
i mean he's being paid by putin so why
not well i mean that's what he's being
paid for that's his job
i mean we get paid by george soros i get
pa you know george soros sends me all
those great big [ __ ] checks in the
mail to me to yell and scream into the
microphone to spread my propaganda why
can't we assume that when this
[ __ ] is in bed with putin going
over there to conferences sitting next
to putin cow towing to him why can't we
assume
that they're getting putin paychecks huh
okay let's see let's um so we got we're
gonna come back to the book burning
video uh once we get gabe on here
usually he comes in about the half hour
mark
uh let's see is there any updates here
let's see
just trying to just trying to find some
updates okay yeah we got an update we'll
go over that as well
we'll go over that as well
um
we got some updates here okay so let's
go to the trendy trends in the tweety
tweets we have number one trending isis
um
us
uh the president here last night at my
direction the u.s military forces let me
get this
u.s military forces successfully
undertook
a counter-terrorism operation thanks to
the bravery of our armed surface we have
removed from the battlefield the leader
of isis
i'm not even gonna try
you can try i'm not i'm not gonna try
there's the name if you want the name
but i'm not even gonna try it
the leader of isis
i you know i tweeted earlier that i
remember being in a timeline
at one point where
um
barack obama
uh killed
osama bin laden do you remember that
timeline do you remember that [ __ ]
timeline when american presidents
actually went out and killed terrorists
that were threats to the american people
do you remember that timeline that we
had it was under a democrat
i wonder
i wonder if that's significant at all
you know there was eight years of a
republican administration that was
hell-bent on war and all kinds of
countries that had nothing to do with
bin laden couldn't find that
[ __ ]
you get a democrat in boom
smoked him smoked bin laden he did
and now we have president biden within
his with just just beyond his first year
smoke the leader of isis remember
remember when the republicans and maga
told us trump destroyed isis he got rid
of isis
oh he did really huh well it's kind of
funny because president biden
just last night killed the leader of
isis it seems like if there was a leader
there's still a group called isis
it really is it really is
these these people
get their [ __ ] head so far up their
asses that they haven't realized what
the hell is going on the the thing i'm
waiting on the thing i'm waiting on is
all the really bad takes about how it's
a horrible thing that joe biden killed
the leader of isis they're they're
[ __ ] coming if they're not already in
this [ __ ] thread
they're coming they're coming trust me
they're gonna say [ __ ] like that oh it's
a bad thing that he killed the leader of
isis joe biden's such a horrible person
because he killed the leader of isis
it's it's coming the bad takes are going
to be there
now let's see what else do we have
mr neuberger says you know the coffee is
flowing at fox news this am as they try
to figure out a way to slam joe biden
for killing the isis leader oh man
they're trying to work up how they're
going to be pro isis this morning like a
[ __ ]
like a [ __ ] over there
well how
we have to be on the side of isis
biden's their enemy and he's our enemy
and we can't have that we have to own
the libs
we have to destroy america to own the
libs that's what we have to do
let's support mr putin
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
it's constant they're not gonna let up
either aaron says here overnight
president biden led the u.s mission that
killed the leader of isis all american
troops have now returned safely from the
operation thank you mr president
i agree
i agree
uh let's see what else do we have here
uh
midas has the uh
the official statement here put out by
president biden uh president biden
announced u.s military forces have
killed the leader of isis in the current
counter-terrorism operation in syria
overnight maybe that's what maybe
that'll be their stance maybe they won't
be pro-isis they'll be like oh well
assad assad you know that murderous
[ __ ] dictator how that guy you know
who knows who knows what these [ __ ]
bad takes are gonna be there's gonna be
[ __ ] plenty of them though you know
it
you know that there's gonna be plenty of
[ __ ] of [ __ ] bad takes
uh here
hey look at here
i guess i guess we need to order we need
a
brian points out ad ordered the mission
to kill leader of isis to the list yes
thank you brian
um i think this rachel rachel bitcoffer
posted this the other day as well um
this is a good little thing if you guys
want i i'm gonna i retweeted this at the
top go copy this [ __ ]
and start spreading that around the
internet like herpes i'm just saying you
know
to spread this little meme around here
what has biden done
a few things
a few things just a couple you know not
a lot a couple uh let's see
um
occupy democrats we got that oh what's
bad company have to say
isis leader i'm not even gonna try it
blew himself up and took others with him
we did not drop a bomb
i don't know what that means
but bad company is assuming something
there does anyone know how to say this
name i i'm it's going to be rough for me
to say this name you know i i'm horrible
with names in general this is a really
long name
it's a really long name okay
let's see what else do we have cnn's got
their thing reuters
um duty to warn let's see what they have
to say president biden last night at my
direction uh u.s military forces
successfully undertook a
counter-terrorism operation thanks to
the bravery of armed service
forces
we have removed from the battlefield
again the leader of isis
i'm not even going to attempt so they're
quoting they're quoting president biden
here
they're quoting president biden
[Music]
isn't it funny how um when democrats are
in power they really do everything they
can um
not to not to to make sure that that the
the american people are safe and they
don't like like go out and run laps
before it happens
and pound their chests before it happens
they just do it to protect the american
people you ever notice that you remember
i mean i'm old enough to remember when
bin laden was killed i'm old enough to
remember it was it was late at night it
wasn't like during the [ __ ] day here
it was late at night here
and when when barack obama came out and
he made the announcement in front of the
podium
uh what what that he had ordered the the
execution and the the raid well here it
is
here it is um looks like joe has this
president biden's remarks today uh on
the killing of isis
leader
um by contrast
okay here here this is this is a
i'm gonna retweet this from joe but
she's pointing out the jimmy kimmel um
has a comparison here
you know what i'm not gonna play it
here's the reason why because they're
gonna knock me on it
jimmy will [ __ ] say no you can't do
that it's copyright
but but i'm going to retweet it anyway
so you guys can go watch it
uh joe says she loves it so much so uh
if joe likes it it must be good so go
take a t go take a look at that
but let's see if we can find another
video of
do do do do do because there's a lot of
stories here um that's the tweet um
but i'm old enough to remember when
barack obama came out and announced that
they killed osama bin laden and like
people descended on the white house they
were out in washington they were
cheering they were singing
usa usa it was it was it was a day that
everyone
had waited for for a long time and a
democrat did that barack obama did that
and then um now we see
after they had you know
continued to continue this [ __ ] lie
that somehow donald trump had gotten rid
of isis we see that president biden
late at night in secret has taken out
the isis leader to protect the american
people and um you know i'm sure he'll
give statements today but it definitely
won't be [ __ ] chess pounding like
that [ __ ] cheeto dust mobster every
time he he the world moved for him
hey look who we got here
hey gabe how are you hey hey oh hey your
mic is on your mic oh wow yeah
the mic is on every everyone likes yeah
well you know everyone likes this
everyone likes the new banners by the
way oh yeah they were saying nice
banners and i gave you credit so thank
you i appreciate it well you know you've
been working hard on the banners you
can't figure out the mic situation but
the banners you got
today's a new day and i got it going
well that's good that's good did you did
you hear we have a really big interview
tomorrow did you hear this i i kind of
know like i feel like let's just say
i'm keeping my eye on it okay keeping
your your eye on it huh yeah yeah okay
well let's let's um do you want to go
over and we'll we'll look at uh maybe
maybe we'll look at a clip that was
posted you think that might work uh
let's see
let's give the people a little taste
yeah give them a little taste of what's
going on um so so um if no one's aware
we're partnering with midas touch to try
to get this interview out there
to get distribution for this interview
so we can get as many eyeballs on this
interview as we possibly can
they just posted a clip on their page
uh exclusive
we all know
by now exclusive yeah exclusive we all
know now
that oat keepers founder stewart rhodes
wore an eye patch because he shot
himself in the eye but for the first
time rhodes estranged wife will tell the
full story on tomorrow's
tony michael's pod follow us here
and it's more humiliating than you can
imagine it's it's it's it's actually
it's actually on brand don't you think
like the story that she tells yeah no it
it's definitely one of those things
where it like starts off and she's like
uh
you know obviously well i guess i'll
start with obviously where he shot
himself in the face but there's
you know different versions that she
goes into
and then explains how the eye patch
actually came to be right because
because really there is several versions
like there's there's several versions
even in the media like we were trying to
look this up over the last few days to
try to figure out like no one's got the
story right
right no one well no one has their story
right and and she was has been with him
since it actually happened like she even
tells that part where they weren't even
married at the time and you know all
this stuff was happening right um but
she tells the story during the interview
now which is that the thing that
everyone wants to know is the story of
why the eye patch they they talk a lot
more in the interview about yeah there's
a ton of ton of nuggets in this
interview there is and it'll play
tomorrow again tomorrow right here on
live
in the first hour the tony michaels
podcast
we'll play it in the very first hour and
then we'll do bonehead the second hour
because we always do bonehead of the
week and and it looks like
um the cheeto dust mobster is going to
win that one don't you think
i would say yeah probably a pretty clear
winner that's the first time he's ever
been on there so it's it's kind of it's
yeah i was actually surprised that uh
it took
that long
for it to happen oh for him to get on
there yeah well i mean you know like for
everything else that's going on it's
like you know he's been he's been in the
back
round mm-hmm you know
getting his fingers in all the pots
and uh all these other people who are
like supporting him get you know they're
the ones who get the face time on
bonehead but he finally
this week
got himself a slot
he did he did he finally made it what
now i mean we could probably put him on
there every week and he would win oh
yeah yeah exactly like he would win you
know he's just like the bonehead of the
day every day right
okay so we'll do that tomorrow after the
interview but let's let's play the
teaser that might just touch uh let me
let me take down this banner hang on a
second let me let me let's let's clear
the double banner double banner let's
clear the way it actually happened in it
and let's rewind
midas has posted this part of the um eye
patch story let's listen now which
brings me to one thing that everyone
wants to know because this is the story
that everyone wants to hear um stuart
where's an eye patch we've seen it in
the in the uh
in the mug shots
and in the tunnel videos like we said
earlier the spider whole
uh tactical whole he did not have an eye
patch so there is a story going around
that he shot himself in the eye um i
don't know how that is what it is do you
guys know the story and can you tell us
the story of how stuart seemed to have
an eye patch okay this is three stories
there is the event
okay and the facts that happened on
there's also this story he told
there's
which is mostly lie
also
what i believe actually happened and it
took me 20 years to piece it together
and then there's the second event which
is why he stopped wearing a prosthetic
eye
um i guess i'll start with him shooting
himself in the face
she'll start with shooting himself in
the vase
um because a lot of people the the story
going around the internet that he was an
instructor and
that um that he somehow shot himself in
the face when he was giving instruction
on shooting
that's that's that's pretty much the
gist of the story that went down on the
internet
yeah uh everyone has been and until this
interview you know we didn't know
ourselves
and the belief was like oh how funny is
that that this guy was a gun instructor
and shot his [ __ ] eye out right
that's hilarious realized that that's
actually not the true story and it's way
better it's way better
i guess it's way way better don't you
think like this yeah like the real
version of this story is way better than
it was so like just listening to it real
time was like oh that happened and oh
but that that actually happened and
that's why he was where he was and doing
what he was doing when that happened
right right and then it was like yeah
because because there's because in in
true stuart rhodes oathkeeper conspiracy
to commit seditious fashion there it
seems like there were crimes committed
like while this was happening right oh
yeah and and it was not only that but
it's like you know she gives deep well
they both give details about it but it's
specifically talking about like
how there was
a crime that was happening right right
and he was like yeah i'm just going to
talk about this crime and how i felt
because because he because like she said
he tells the story the way he wants to
tell it right right exactly and then she
pieces together over the 20 years like
what the actual story is and then the
other piece of it is why where's the eye
patch because we even because of the eye
patch and the texas thing we even talk a
little bit about um dan crenshaw oh yeah
that sort of thing um you know yeah well
you know you got these uh these texas
pirates are yeah exactly but they go
into exactly why
why that eye patch is there and it's
[Music]
well it's kind of gnarly
well yeah it's a let's just say
everyone's saying it's a juicy story it
is a juicy story the ipad so so
make sure
make sure to uh tomorrow to
check that out also go to uh minus touch
page i'll retweet this here
um and we'll give them we read it we
give credit even though it's our video
you know but we give credit oh that's
not what we're doing
that's it that's how it happens here
there we go
maybe
maybe
i'm just got it off wow how many cups of
coffee have you not had today well you
know it takes me about six to get here
so
yeah five or six i do i to get to this
level of fire every day i have to have
five or six cups of coffee like a whole
[ __ ] pot that's crazy i don't drink
coffee so i don't know what that's like
well you know the other day the other
day i had to cut out early i don't know
if everyone noticed but i cut like five
minutes early and the reason why is
because i was gonna piss my pants like i
had to cut early because it the coffee
was not it wouldn't get it it wasn't
gonna happen i guess it's better than
the other alternative well you know i i
mean i i i'm not like the cheeto dust
mobster or and where the depends just
well you could you could sit here
i could start doing it yeah just put
them on and just be like listen i'm here
locked in all day let's go do you
remember the story years ago about the
astronaut she she put on diapers and she
drove across the country so she didn't
have to stop do you remember
yeah you don't remember that crazy yeah
she was an astronaut
i don't know but she was an astronaut
and she put on a diaper she drove across
the country and she and she had on
diapers so that way she didn't have to
stop um you know because she was gonna
go i don't know if she was gonna beat up
some boyfriend or something so you're
telling me that every time she stopped
to get gas she never went well i i don't
know about that i'm not sure i mean you
know a tank of gas will last you about
what 300 miles you know 350 miles right
you know and depending on how fast
you're going you know that's several
hours right
maybe she had a weak bladder and she had
to go every so i mean is she going from
one coast to the other so she's got like
10 potential stops i i believe the story
is and this has been a long time but i
believe the story is is that it's
they were she was driving from florida
to texas or from texas to florida okay
it's not as far but right i guess
it's pretty [ __ ] far that's pretty
[ __ ] hard for texas to florida come
on in a car that's that's a long time i
don't know why she just didn't get a
plane ticket i'm not sure uh okay i had
to look this up okay yeah 900 i'm not
crying
lisa nowak yep there you go drove 900
miles she would attack
her
the diaper wearing astronaut jailed
jailed yup yup i mean
ex
ex's girlfriend oh okay so it was her ex
okay so i knew the boyfriend was in
there and x and it was a domestic kind
of dispute uh but i've never i've never
seen this movie but lucy in the sky is
the movie that's from twenty there's a
[ __ ] movie is based
her actions inspired the 2019 movie lucy
in the sky so she says kaelyn says she's
in prison
yeah yeah i know she texts she's that
was
i don't know if it's in texas i mean i
guess that's where the crime was
committed so you'd probably be profane
says she had cans of gas too she had
cans of gas oh so she was i mean again
she's stuck whatever you know so maybe
she didn't stop at a gas station like
she would stop
get out wherever she was at fill up the
tank
piss her pants a little bit and then
head on down the road
but you know this might not be a bad
theory when i drink so much coffee and
now we have the two-hour show i mean i
was thinking i was thinking well maybe i
just do a bigger break with a few more
commercials no gives me time no no i
could just get just i just want you to
keep all right
i just got to keep talking you've got to
commit you know right like you can meet
yourself and be like oh there was a
movement but
you can't get up you have to stay in the
chair you have to entertain the masses
tony that's right that's right we gotta
we gotta keep it going we can't stop we
can not stop
speaking that tomorrow is the interview
is gonna be great it's going to be
fantastic and it's got it's got all
kinds of juicy stuff in it like not
exactly not exactly not exactly like um
like astronaut wearing and diaper
wearing astronauts type stuff but it
depends it gets
right it depends
it gets pretty close yeah yeah it gets
close it gets
pretty good there are there are some
because because um
some news out there um that happened um
what i mean just in the last couple of
weeks with the stewart rhodes right
about the tunnels right everyone was
wondering about the tunnels there was a
couple videos and a couple pictures of
him like in a in a tunnel right which
weren't the ones which right there was
the practice tunnels not the actual
tunnels right right those are those were
a little different thing and actually uh
dakota
um stewart's son and tasha's son go into
what those were versus what the
escape tunnels that everyone's been
talking about was right um and also they
explained kind of um how that came to be
and actually who dug them and all that
kind of stuff they kind of go into that
so um if you're wondering about the
escape tunnels as well don't miss the
interview and i i just want to talk
about an hour and 15 minutes right yeah
an hour and 15. okay yeah yeah so you
know it's a it's a it's a tight hour 15.
okay it's 75. tight okay uh but i i do
want to point out that we are the only
place that has an interview with both
tasha and dakota that is true that is
everyone else has mainly been
interviewing tasha because obviously
estranged wife and there's a couple
places that i've had dakota on but no
one's been able to put them together and
had them to basically like
great
yeah from both sides right because
because tasha was married to him
well she's been with him right you know
um for for you know
she's known him for 30 years right filed
one horse in 2018 right right right
um and she's still working on that i
guess now that he's in federal detention
it'll probably be a lot easier right
but
uh dakota
was there with stewart
during a lot of the militia stuff and he
knows a lot of the stuff about like
bundy ranch because that's another thing
that people want to know and have been
talking about right um
a round steward in a story around him
being detained and arrested and charged
with seditious conspiracy is the bundy
rant so they talk about that as well and
there's
they think there's something significant
about the bundy ranch that you'll see in
the interview
of maybe how it's connected to
what he did on january 6th so
you know i don't know you might want to
tune in tomorrow morning
tomorrow noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
the west coasters west coast baby you
people out there and italian valley
california in california um
so so
if you do miss it though if you do miss
it don't worry it's it'll be on the
youtube channel so just go subscribe to
the youtube channel
and it'll be there we're also going to
be
working with midas because midas is our
partner in distribution of this
interview because we did want to get it
out to as many people as we possibly
could we felt that it was a very
significant interview um i felt that
there was a lot of important stuff in it
to kind of debunk some of the stuff not
just like the eye patch and the gun
thing right but um
tell tasha's story and tell dakota's
story because they do have a story
surrounding um stuart rhodes they i mean
they are human beings and they would did
have to live with this stuff and they
have to live with it every day now like
right they didn't they didn't choose for
this to happen to them yeah so they have
a story to tell and i feel like it's
very significant very important and i
think as many people that can watch it
should and also tasha and and dakota are
on twitter um you should go follow them
they do tweet a lot of stuff about the
stewart rhodes case um actually i think
dakota tweeted yesterday that there
there was like um
did you see bill collectors we're
calling for students
um stewart or something
oh no yeah and he he he said in the
tweet he had to refer him to the fbi let
me let me go see it
[Music]
yeah yeah he said he had to refer him to
the uh the fbi
uh let's see if i can find that
like if you're looking for him he's
currently incarcerated uh awaiting trial
so yeah so here here's dakota's uh this
is tasha's son um dakota's in the
interview with tasha
you can follow him dakota v adams
but
here it is here's the tweet
just got a call from the debt collection
agency looking for stewart i referred
them to the fbi
uh so you still got a sense of humor
about this stuff at least yeah you know
they still got a sense of humor
oh man okay kathy griffin is oh yeah she
was looking for him the other day yeah
yeah so uh it's kathy if you're out
there i'll i'll um see if we can wow
your life whew
um let's see
kathy if you're out there we'll have
this interview you should you should
watch it dakota will
give his take so also if you want to
come on the show you know
well you know i i would not be opposed
for kathy griffin to come on the show i
like to ask her a lot of stuff there's a
lot of things i'd like to ask kathy so
kathy if you're listening
you know come on the show yeah also uh
um you know i don't want to brag or
anything yeah but uh
kathy griffin
is an alumni of my high school so you
know oh really so it's like you two are
kind of like classmates is that
everything is it kind of like you and
christian walker being roommates is it
like an internet type thing no it's a
real thing like oh it's a real thing
yeah like we are legitimately alumni of
the same high school oh okay yeah same
as dan castellaneta who's the voice of
homer simpson we got a few people in
there oh so so you so you're like in a
part of this elite group then yeah i
mean i would hopefully at some point i
like to throw my name on be like yeah
i'm associated with these people however
right now right now i'm i'm just a
nobody you know just well you know maybe
maybe you'll get there i don't know if
the [ __ ] list will take you there but
maybe it will
um
speaking of hollywood elites and um um
everyone calls her a [ __ ] lib
you know i i i had to mention jenny
mccarthy's name earlier because she
started trending um you know
because of the rudy giuliani which will
get to the mask or the is it called the
unmasked singer what what is this
showcase
it's called the mask singing
right because you're singing and you're
masked you know i also feel like
uh
uh unmasking rudy giuliani on tv right
like just feels like
a a real-life version of scooby-doo like
the scene where they just like pull off
like oh i would have gotten away if it
weren't for you like meddling kids
that's the moment
that i imagine it happens you do villain
right exactly they pull off the mask you
know from rudy giuliani he's there
leaking hair dying and everything you
know because that thing is not
cold or cool right it's it's it's hot
and so
knowing
his past i would say that he's probably
sweating bullets and those bullets were
uh you know
printer ink guy so well yeah what what
song was he singing did they say they
don't know they don't know they just
said that it was reported that he was on
the show they unmasked him and then ken
jong and robin thicke walked away and i
also want to say that if robin thicke
walks away the dude
who has a ton of scandal behind him
cheating all that stuff you know the
blurred lines guy if he walks away
when you're on stage you know you're bad
right right you're not doing it right
yeah you know that you're a bonehead
right well maybe maybe he will end up in
the bonehead of the week tomorrow um
susan sarandon
to go back to her not to distract from
her i really i don't want to even talk
about her but a tweet from actor susan
sarandon is discussed after thousands of
police officers attended the funeral of
new york uh police officer joseon jason
rivera excuse me and wilbur mora on
january 28th and february 2nd
so there are some cops that were killed
in new york and apparently she post
reposted or retweeted something um here
here's the
let's see
i really
this is i can't even be believe this is
a [ __ ] thing that we're talking about
today
but we are
here's a mystery solvent oh i get it
susan's random is a crazy person
um so this is the the tweet and i guess
it's uh
i guess it's a picture of like the the
funeral procession right right it's a
law enforcement funeral process for the
cops that were recently killed right and
and the original tweet says i'm gonna
tell kids this is what fascists look
like and then she she says so if all
these cops weren't needed for crime you
know on capital letters that day doesn't
that mean they aren't needed any day
um so is she for or against police
reform i i'm not sure
is she for against anything really i
don't know i mean she's got terrible
takes all the time she's also the same
one that thought that hillary clinton
was even more dangerous than donald
trump right
now
well you know what's you know as funny
as is that you know
maga you know that let's go brandon
nazis or like oh you liberals are so bad
that susan sarandon's a leftist i'm like
what are you talking about a leftist
when has she ever shown herself to be a
leftist i don't know i don't know i mean
i mean does she retweet left
people does she have
really
i think she's she's as middle as you can
get on the left you know like she's
right she's like jimmy mccarthy type
right
right come on
this is not this is
which would also make sense why she was
stayed on stage just chatting up with
rudy giuliani well the other thing too
about
about uh susan sarandon is the only
reason why we really have this big view
of susan sarandon is you brought it up
in 2016 the media had her on everywhere
yeah because she would go on and torch
hillary clinton and spread [ __ ] lies
right
you know that's how it goes uh let's go
back to the the trendy trends i'm sick
and tired of hearing about her we'll go
to the um
let's see we have the mass singer before
we go it looks like we got a birthday in
the comments here though mj's posting
balloons veteran yoda
um uh it's kaylin's birthday it looks
like robin says happy birthday kaylin so
everyone wish katelyn a happy birthday
in the in the comments
happy birthday happy
birthday yeah well i i figured the mask
singer we would sing happy birthday so
if you're in the comments
sing happy birthday to caitlyn happy
birthday caitlyn okay so
deadline hollywood exclusive rudy
giuliani
was last week unmasked
as the exiting costume contestant in the
taping of the first episode of the match
i just want to know do you think they
will air this episode absolutely
oh yeah why wouldn't you yeah why do you
think they're floating it i mean they're
floating that's that's the whole reason
they're they're looking for the pr
around it and we're and we're
contributing to it baby that's why they
brought rudy giuliani on in the first
place i mean they knew this they knew it
would be this this thing right i mean
i've never watched the show i don't know
what it is um i've never basically okay
what happens is
these people sing
or
sing
uh with a full body costume and then
uh they ask questions
and then they are able to like answer
those questions or give hints or
whatever i think and then from there
they say
uh and i think they're also like i've
seen one episode
and they also do like a little bit of a
like a like oh this person does this and
likes that and
this is the industry this person's in
and from those clues and whatever the
song choice is because the song is a
hint
at
who they are
then
um
the judges go through and basically like
process the elimination try to figure
out who this person is underneath the
mask right so so
what's the competition who wins what how
do you [ __ ] win you just keep
going like each week you don't want to
be unmasked so you want to go to the
very end you want to stay so it is very
possible that rudy giuliani of course he
probably can't sing worth the [ __ ] i
mean he can't put hair dye on where the
[ __ ] he can't schedule a press
conference at a decent [ __ ] location
worth the [ __ ] at least we know that if
he were to fart and spread covet it
would just stay within the costume well
that is true you know jenna ellis is
nowhere near right grandpa farty
mcshardy you know that's my moniker that
i get
count flatula
[Laughter]
oh so but the story really is not that
just rudy giuliani
but a couple people walked off stage
these judges
that you were saying walked off stage
yeah ken jung and robin thicke and i
think
i think that's going to be in the
episode for sure um you know this is
reality tv this is why our country's
[ __ ] you know going down the [ __ ]
tubes is because we had to have these
people in charge this reality tv show
show show [ __ ] and charge our [ __ ] show
whichever one you want to go with i mean
really honestly
it is funny how you look back at it and
you're like alright sean spicer in 2019
was right dancing with the stars sarah
palin was on unmatched on the math
singer in 2020
rudy giuliani 2022 like
these people have no careers after their
affiliation with trump or the republican
party it's not like they can continue on
and actually be successful politicians
or a big [ __ ] surprise though really
no not at all it only further pushes
this idea that republicans are just
there to
i mean because you know in my way like
the way i see reality tv is kind of like
junk food in any ways right you're not
great you know you get something out of
it but you're not getting like real
substance
and
that's all republicans are right it's a
you know like you say wrestlemania in
reality it's a it's a combination of the
two and right now we're literally
watching politicians go on to reality tv
shows because they literally have
nothing else to do they're they are
irrelevant if they are not in the public
eye on these on these shows
um not to not to take a dig at the shows
because you know i mean rudy giuliani
can be in the public eye right now
without putting a [ __ ] mask on and
act like he could sing oh yeah i mean i
mean he could he could definitely be in
the public eye for singing just maybe to
like the january sixth select community
or prosecutors yeah you know i mean i'm
just saying or right i mean that's what
i was saying yesterday i was like oh
soon enough he'll come out and say that
this thing was rigged and there was
fraud
we might have to have a recount an
awesome yeah
i want to i want to yeah i want the
cyber ninjas to come in make sure
there's no bamboo ballots and [ __ ]
exactly yeah you know i mean
it's on brand for these [ __ ]
dan says if you thought the new episode
of the mass singer with rudy giuliani
was bad in episode two vladimir putin is
unmasked and all the judges are poisoned
oh my god yep well
would you put it past the producers of
the mass singer to try to get vlady
daddy on i mean they got rudy giuliani
on why wouldn't yeah right that's
exactly like i could just see the
unmasking is like hello people i'm
vladimir putin and then boom
unmasked singer
and it's like a huge red curtain comes
down
and wait wait have you ever done have
you ever done uh a video with vladimir
putin in it no i did do a video so i had
a series of videos and maybe they'll
come back at some point but i did a
series of videos where there was the
white house pr guy and he was in the
trump administration and then he had
come over to the biden administration
but in one of the episodes uh
on during the biden administration there
is a uh a russian um
like handyman that's in there you know
and there's a mistake between poutine
and putin right like do you say putin
he's like no i say putin very good
so so kind of yeah so uh that's the
closest i've ever had to a putin cameo
in one of my videos but who knows you
know maybe maybe putin or beer i don't
know you do a pretty good putin i i
don't know putin but yeah mike flynn
does mike flynn knows
yeah you see this mike flynn um let's go
to that speaking of mike flynn and putin
we're just we're just transitioning in
the news here like crazy let's see there
is so much stuff
well the [ __ ] list is long especially
can you keep up that's basically what
life is right now can you keep up no
well we're going anyway yeah well
let's see let's go to the let's see if
we can find the michael flynn
oh
let's see if we can find this there's
several videos cause this [ __ ] just
can't shut his [ __ ] mouth you know um
you remember we had heidi kuda on it was
was that december
and uh jim stewartson had um did a video
of mike flynn basically copying pasting
and i forget the name right off hand but
a cult leader dakota dakota even brings
that up and that's true that's true he
does bring up mike flynn and how mike
flynn has significance also alex jones
oh yeah
that was i wasn't expecting that one
yeah well so so you know make sure to
watch the interview tomorrow see all
this stuff ties itself in together
um but uh
you remember the the video that jim put
out
and ever since that happened the q anon
universe has been very skeptical of mike
flynn and they really kind of have
started to divide up where he has his
supporters but he definitely is still
mike lindell in the the mind pelo nazi
is definitely on mike flynn's side and
here um here's this on mike lindell's tv
um and i think this is the one where
he's
uh giving fellatio to putin let's listen
okay but to encroach further by nato uh
and and and act as though anybody that
wants to join nato can come in it
doesn't work that way especially as you
get closer to a border of a large nation
state with nuclear weapons and uh and a
leader who is not uh you know who's a
strong leader i mean
that's so he's talking about vladimir
putin there he's not talking about the
the leader of ukraine which is our ally
and and is the the country that they
want in nato to protect that country
that is our ally who is you know what
you know what's funny
is how much these people conflate the
idea between supporting putin and
criticizing nato
and
uh because i've seen it because i did a
tweet yesterday and a bunch of the or
you know it got shared onto instagram
which was basically it was the josh
hawley and it was like you know tell me
you work for putin without telling me
right right that's a comment only
specifically about holly's decision to
say pull out right to support russia to
be anti-biden
and people are like which is
anti-american because that's our foreign
policy and i'm not and i'm not yeah i'm
not commenting on nato and their history
i'm commenting specifically on these
people these republicans who are now
very much pro-russia and pro-putin right
and that's the criticism and then these
people come in and they're like oh
neoliberalism blah blah blah like oh
yeah and it's and i saw someone like you
know you can criticize one person person
for being a fascist right while not
supporting this other thing right it's
all the people that are making this that
are conflating the two are republicans
of course because they're saying
well but it's the same [ __ ] that
they do about these books and we're
going to get to the book bernie where
they want a band to kill a mockingbird
because it has the n word in it but they
don't understand the context of the book
and because they don't
read well they don't want to read it
they don't know how to they're scared to
read it and if they because if they do
read it you know it might you know like
wake something up in their brain and go
oh maybe maybe context matters right
might make them feel something well
they'll feel something which would be
very odd
the guy's a very strong leader he's been
he's been in charge for a long time and
he's not going to put up with uh the
nonsense that that he's seen in europe
this is a foreign uh a former excuse me
a former [ __ ] general in our military
right
now we're just gonna just straight up
support him don't even care well if you
cut that out and you pasted it you know
two decades ago or 15 years ago when
mike flynn was an officer
in the united states military you would
think he would be talking about a united
states president but he's not he's
talking about vladimir putin who is a
[ __ ] murderous dictator right and
this is this [ __ ] [ __ ] that they do
and the reason why they [ __ ] love
putin is because it's all a [ __ ]
grift putin is a gift it's not democracy
it's not it's not democracy in russia
they don't have democracy it's [ __ ]
rigged up that's what they want here
that's what they love about him the most
is that he fixes it up makes it look
like democracy and all the people chose
me get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] mike flynn what a [ __ ] traitor
again i said [ __ ] mine flynn arrest that
[ __ ] um i i actually
my personal my personal opinion is that
when the january 6 select committee's
done and we have grand juries out of
washington dc that have gone through
this seditious conspiracy i believe
there's going to be someone
someone tried and indicted on the t word
and mike flynn is uh very close to that
okay let's um let's see i want to go
back let's go to my timeline speaking of
burning books
we'll transition we're almost one hour
into the show here
uh
[Music]
let's see
we had it here somewhere of course i
retweeted a ton of [ __ ] here
there we go uh tennessee holler has this
this is uh you know the the pastor greg
lock you remember this guy yeah the one
that was uh banned i think twice from or
suspended twice from twitter
right uh yeah possibly you know i'm not
i'm not 100 sure of um
exactly why he was he was banned i think
it was the coven misinformation is that
what you're saying i i believe so i mean
yeah typical like uh save yourself uh
the va you know the virus is the
antichrist
right right well this is the same
[ __ ] that would have uh circus
tents
right you remember this he would have he
would have a circus tent
and he would literally be having church
in the circus then now everyone's gonna
say well tony that's how they do
revivals
but this guy was only doing church in a
circus tent yeah like that's it
um and of course here he's showing
burning books and i'm sure
i'm sure in this bag and i i want to
show this video let's um let's pull down
the banner here just so we can see the
words that they got on here
you know if i would look at this video
and not be given context i'd be like is
that 1940s germany
well i mean these people are yelling and
screaming around the fire the thing i
want to show you here is this is the
most interesting part so he's got these
he's got the bag of what we presume is
books in the barrel right and then watch
as he pulls it out i think this is very
interesting
he wants to make sure no one stuck any
bibles in there or something
yeah
because that book talks i mean let's
let's be honest here right the bible
talks about certain stories how did we
populate the earth from just
siblings okay just putting out well you
know right it's incest it wasn't like
god made additional people he started
with adam and eve and then there were
the 12 tribes and it's like how did they
come to be
people were [ __ ] each other and well
they were yeah mm-hmm it's basically
like what you're saying what you're
saying is is
um if there's any book that they should
be against and they should burn it's the
bible
well
good i i bet there isn't one bible at
this book burning no
not to even not not to just to burn but
to even you know you know what else is
funny about this is they bought those
books most likely
yeah then right they purchased them yeah
so like to own the libs to own the
book publishers we're gonna buy the
books and then burn the books and
they're like
okay bernie books just keep buying and
burning yeah they're like whatever i
guess it doesn't take up as much space
but we still get the same money but this
is like when you know they went on and
on about the nfl when colin kaepernick
which colin kaepernick's in the news too
we'll probably get to that today
um colin kaepernick
kneeled during the national anthem in
solidarity with black lives matter and
and
black people being killed by police
they didn't understand it they thought
he was against the military and all this
[ __ ] so um you remember they were
burning all their nfl gear their jerseys
their hats their coats and [ __ ] and the
nfl's like well that's [ __ ] fantastic
you're just gonna have to buy all new
[ __ ] right like i'm good with that like
and they really don't understand i mean
it's the same people who got pissed off
at like lebron james burned his jersey
and then bought new jerseys
he came back well yeah well i mean
what else would they do
this is all the [ __ ] just nonsense
again
i had someone because i tweeted
something the other day about burning
books and i actually was banning to kill
a mockingbird and someone's like this is
a leftist thing i'm like no it's not
just because they're [ __ ] doing a
psyop on the reason that leftists used
to want to cancel the book to kill a
mockingbird doesn't mean their goal is a
left-leaning goal that's such a bunch of
[ __ ] because the the oh well there's the
n-word in it that's why they want to get
rid of it that they're using that as the
excuse right that's right that is not
why
right they
it's the context of the book that
they're terrified of and really what
they're even more terrified of is people
actually reading it
so i mean my suggestion and you know
really honestly when they do this book
burning book banning thing especially
when they pick out a particular book a
specific one it just gives more you know
noise towards that book and hopefully
more people will go read and and
actually digest the content of that book
because there is more um in the killing
mockingbird than just racism like this
you know this institutional racism that
happens in our country there's a lot
more to that story right um but they're
focused in on that one word
because in in decades past a lot of
people have wanted to cancel that book
um also like adventures of huckleberry
finn
by mark twain they for the same reason
of that word is in the book and really
my opinion is that
people of color in this country
absolutely are not scared of that word
especially when it's in the context of a
book um of those two books showing why
it's a really [ __ ] stupid thing
yeah and also
and also like these people that are you
know these republicans or you know
whoever else on that group are the ones
wanting to ban these books they're like
oh it says the n word it's like you were
totally okay saying the n word to
someone in public right so shut the [ __ ]
up right okay let's go brandon nazis
right let's watch let's watch uh pastor
lock here have this fun with these books
so he checks it
tosses it in
do they have horns that they're tooting
yeah they're like you know boozellas or
something like that it's just it's like
i know what the [ __ ] is this
yeah they're trying to be manly right
macho i mean it is it is really man i
mean it shows how big of a dick you have
right when you're willing to get a bag
of books and throw them on a bonfire in
a crowd full of alpha cucks
one man tries to be the most alpha
cuckiest of all
his name greg luck uh you know maybe
maybe there's a video here i don't know
you should be taking notes yeah well
but no no you're right you're right this
is an alpha cuck bonfire yeah
how do i show that i'm the [ __ ] alpha
i throw a book into a burning fire like
right oh of us
i made this fire with pallets it looks
like and i'm burning books that i bought
so
[ __ ] you libs like right
okay so you're you're you're burning
pallets and you're burning books this is
also also the same group that's like oh
boyden is trashing the economy you
literally are contributing to the
economy growing or supporting these
publishers or this business or whatever
it is so i love it i love it i think i
think look more like let's go brandon
nazis that way in 2022 we can really
make sure i mean
these people are supposed to be the ones
for education and younkin yunkan in in
in
virginia one on education these people
are burning [ __ ]
books yeah and they're for education
come on give me a [ __ ] break
we i i would never even if even if there
was a stack of mine com
i i wouldn't burn them i wouldn't ban
them either i wouldn't ban it i i would
want people to read how [ __ ] how
[ __ ] sick fascism is and let them
decide and i'm sure those people are
totally fine with mineconf oh
they i don't i
i i don't hear anyone talking about
burning mine comp [ __ ] no [ __ ] no they
wouldn't and really maybe that's what he
was doing is checking to make sure his
copy of minecomp yeah wasn't he's like
this one was first edition autographed
by adolf himself right i can't burn that
[ __ ] book no no that book goes up on
the shelf behind me right
[ __ ] [ __ ] goddamn let's go brandon
nazi
wait wait wait what did what was that
how you doing
oh just just a couple just a couple
karen's talking
books
yeah there you go that'll show them
look at this crowd do you have any more
books that we purchased to burn yeah
yeah woohoo
we don't look like let's go brandon
nazis at all yeah with that [ __ ] all
right let's give uh
tennessee holler credit for their video
here somebody runs through show me you
know
right right
well you know it happens uh let's see
what else do we have on the training
trains how much time do you got
uh i got like 10 minutes okay uh let's
go to a break we'll come back and we'll
figure out a subject and then we'll
we'll let gabe go he's got to go do some
more work yeah so let's go to break
we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for staying with us on the break
we're gonna try to uh
[Music]
we're gonna try to make sure gabe gets
out of here on time um is there any is
there any other subject that you wanted
to talk about today um we did the pardon
blanket thing i i i i
i feel like that commercial is a good
commercial especially for the time i
don't know that that one yeah yeah this
is me this is me writing these
commercials months ago and thinking like
ah you know and then not anticipating be
like well i guess they're all still
timely
right well i mean the the um you've seen
the uh report
uh occupy democrats posted let's go back
to that speaking of pardons uh that
uh adam's shift said that
the former president united states
here it is
uh announces offers to pardon his
insurrection this is very important
evidence
um
i would imagine the reason why grandpa
poopypants the cheetah dust mobster
stood on stage and his promising pardons
i would imagine it's because that the
evidence that he collected that the
supreme court said yes the national
archives has to hand over to the select
committee i would imagine that that kind
of shit's in there what do you think
because we've seen we've seen these
documents these executive orders of
unplugging machines and all this other
sedition
where they were ripped up they had to
tape them back together that's the
reports that we're getting
yeah i when did you make the pardon
blanket video do you remember when this
was
yeah i can tell you right now hold on
because
you know
this is what we keep talking about when
we say it is so hard to parody
and use
i
made the part in blanket
on
let's see
sorry i've got so many videos i'm going
through a list of stuff
um
sorry you have a new you have a new
commercial while you're looking there
called
the the droop is that what it's called
it's called the group yeah i think we'll
put that on um tomorrow we'll we'll make
sure that works its way i made this
video october
25th
october 25th
is when i made part and blanket of 20 20
21.
and and that was a rat about that i
guess that's right about the time that
the rolling stone article came out
correct yep
so that's that's when they got the
reports that members of congress
possibly
uh goes are
and that's why he's the the feature in
there but also marjorie taylor green
matt gates lauren bobert some others
that were suspected uh mo brooks
of course mo brooks is the one that were
the uh
bulletproof that's the thing yeah why
would you need a wearable professor i
don't know i don't know i don't know but
um but here
adam schiff
is saying
that this is going to be significant
evidence
where the intent was shown for violence
um
and and
he's talking about a criminal trial
so this is completely different than the
january 6th select committee because
what people have to understand is the
january 6th select committee is not a
criminal investigation they can't charge
anyone with crimes now they can refer
for crimes but they can't charge right
so so what adam schiff is getting at
here is that hey we're probably going to
refer crimes to a criminal trial
so i think that's the read between the
lines message so i think
that the pardon blanket commercial
[Laughter]
it's it's going to be relevant for quite
some time yeah you know it it is really
i will say this it is really hard when
you're making you know uh political
satire
and parodies that you're like oh
i can make this now and i've got a
certain window of time
un
until like
the news cycle refreshes and something
else comes out there and it becomes
irrelevant
uh and that's why a lot of people like
oh i'm gonna make more evergreen content
you know on like oh can you relate to
this like oh companies be like or
whatever it's like or this is you know
you know when you're trying to
do x and y
but when it comes to political satire it
is hard to
to stay
on top of it all but also stay relevant
with something that that goes
you know more than just the two weeks
that it's in the cycle and this happens
to be one of them where
i didn't anticipate it i was like oh
okay it's going to be talked about and
that was it right and this is before the
january 6 committee i think formed
itself yes it was well in that well
no no no i think they were formed they
just hadn't done many uh
they weren't very active at that right i
think at that point everyone was like is
are they gonna like okay they formed it
but what does that mean right
they weren't very publicly active they
were developing all the staff and trying
to because they got mountains of
evidence that they had right yeah i mean
they're literally going through the
receipts they had to hire i don't know
how many dozens of lawyers to to funnel
through this um this evidence but back
to the parity because
we've talked about this before when you
do satire and parody like you have to
take it to the next level right yeah
yeah and sometimes i'm just like i don't
even know how right with these people
you can't but it is doesn't it say
something when you're satire when you go
from well they're already level 12 we
got to go to level 18 or 20. and it
stays relevant for a year yeah like
that's how [ __ ] out of their minds
they are that's how ridiculous all this
stuff is to say to say that all
democrats and republicans are exactly
the same that's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah they are not the same that
that is a total [ __ ] lie that is a
total
shitty narrative it is not real
democrats and republicans are two
separate things at this point yeah yeah
you literally have the republican party
who tried to overthrow the government of
the united states in the name of donald
trump with an attempt of the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
who
absolutely 100
backs
vladimir putin vlady daddy they're
putin's puppies
he was on the cover of [ __ ] newsmax
i remember that didn't you didn't you do
a parody of the i did it i did it let me
see if i can find him oh my god we just
you can't stop with this stuff speaking
of [ __ ] speaking of boneheads while
gage looking for this we do have the
bone end of the week pull up um at tony
michael's pod go follow us there uh josh
holly speaking of [ __ ]
putin's puppy josh hawley is 29 donald
trump at 62
and thomas massey at eight are almost
eight it's hard to even remember
there's been so many boneheads since
thomas massey of what he said i think i
actually asked you that yesterday when
like put my massey on there and i'm like
yeah i don't even remember what he did
but josh hawley
the reason why he's on here is because
he was you know giving fellatio to
bladdy daddy right
of course we know what i sent you i sent
you the link but yeah josh hawley is uh
you know
loves rubbing him out to putin on the
pornhub maybe maybe you know what maybe
it's actually putin hub
is it putin is there just yeah putin hub
it's probably better check you better
check that we make sure you capture that
url
welcome to putin hub oh [ __ ] cause we
got alphacuts.com we're still trying to
figure out what the hell to do with that
um but yeah i'm sure you'll come up with
something yeah let's see here so this is
the um oh here it is
let's see let's
ah come on
there we go
yeah newsmax biden's war on the suburbs
did it actually say that or yeah yeah
every no no the only thing i changed in
this magazine cover was the photo of
vladimir putin and then i i
vladi the zaddy yeah you had to change
that right yeah yeah no i get well that
was a new photo new hat new text on the
photo itself the top area that's all
what so this is the real thing that's
real that is real news max
you know it's the best part is it's 4.99
who would pay 4.99 for this but also
it's like independent american
yo let me suck vladimir's right right
we totally we totally are free thinkers
yeah yeah and we love america
and by that we mean we are anti whatever
biden is even if it means supporting
yeah vlady the zaddy
in this verse reagan would be rolling
over in his grave well we talked about
this the other day didn't we where
reagan mr gorbachev tear down this
especially because people are always
like oh you know we're the party of
lincoln we're the party of reagan and
it's like okay well if reagan was still
in office or alive
uh
he would not feel the same way as you
but all right yeah sure go ahead fine by
me well you know all right are you are
you out of here is that all right
getting out of here all right well uh
thanks for joining us we'll go back to
the trendy trends and the tweety tweets
we got we got about 40 minutes left in
the hour uh stay right here we'll take a
break we'll see you when we get when we
get uh on the other side of the break
thanks for joining us gabe we'll see you
tomorrow thanks for having me
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babel mega
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us here
we always like when gabe comes in
everyone likes gabe white skates videos
but we also have to give gabe a lot of
credit um the reason why we have to give
him a lot of credit is because he's
changing the banners he's doing all the
artwork um and he put this great
interview together i don't know if you
guys know this but when we do these
interviews we do them in post which
means we record them and then gabe edits
them out to make them look all nice and
fancy
and we normally play trivia during the
interview
but with this interview with uh tasha
and dakota adams stuart rhodes uh
ex-wife and uh tasha's son
we weren't able to play trivia because
we just we talked for so long they had
so many stories to tell and we just we
just didn't want them to stop telling
the stories and honestly um
they they both have way more to talk
about about these subjects than just the
hour and 15 minutes that we have the the
75 strong as gabe called it
and we're gonna play that tomorrow
morning um during the podcast so the the
first the first hour or so of the
podcast about the first hour and a half
or so will be the interview uh with
tasha adams and her son dakota uh who is
um estranged from uh stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers
who was charged with seditious
conspiracy to overturn the united states
constitution and who was being detained
in oklahoma he was um
he was actually deposed yesterday
apparently for six [ __ ] hours by the
january 6 select committee
which is very significant again i i bet
the diapers were fooled down at my
mar-a-lago they probably had a lot of
changing to do yesterday midas touch is
actually i want to announce that too
uh i want to thank the mizellas brothers
and midas touch
over there for helping us distribute
this interview uh they posted this clip
that we have about the eye patch um and
the eye patch story which is
which is a story that everyone everyone
wants um to to know
because everyone's getting it wrong on
the internet like me and gabe were
saying earlier the story that they're
telling on the internet about the
instructor thing is not is not true it's
not true that
i'm not saying it's a lie but it's a lie
it's not true
um the actual story
that tasha tells and dakota tells
because
the story that comes out of stuart
rhodes mouth about how he lost his eye
and why he has the high patch um you're
gonna find that out tomorrow
on the tony michaels podcast in that
first hour uh we'll go through that but
let's let's um
let's listen to this clip again so you
guys can see it
and go retweet this
uh spread it around so everyone knows
this interview because i'm sure
everyone's going to want to see this the
full interview um but uh but let's watch
the clip now which brings me to one
thing that everyone wants to know
because this is the story that everyone
wants to hear
um stuart where's an eye patch we've
seen it in the in the uh
in the mug shots
and in the tunnel videos like we said
earlier the spider whole
uh tactical whole he did not have an
ipad so there is a story going around
that he shot himself in the eye um i
don't know how that is what it is do you
guys know the story and can you tell us
the story of how stuart seemed to have
an eye patch all right this is three
stories there is the event
okay and the facts that happened
and there's also this story he told
there's which is mostly lie
there's
also
what i believe actually happened and it
took me 20 years to piece it together
and then
there's the second event which is why he
stopped wearing a prosthetic eye um i
guess i'll start with him shooting
himself in the face
start with shooting himself in the face
so so check that out tomorrow you'll get
the full story of how stuart rhodes
actually shot himself in the
face oh geez
i i can't even believe that um that this
is a story there's so much more to
stuart rhodes and the oath keepers and
there's so much in this interview that
is surprising
and it's not surprising like you think
it would be surprising
uh it there's a lot of stuff in there
where they talk about the oath keepers
the evolution of the oath keepers
um if stewart rhodes was always a trump
supporter uh dakota and tasha talk about
if stewart was always
all in with donald trump and then if he
was or he wasn't
how that came to be and and how he got
in the position where he showed up at
january 6. also like me and gabe said
they talk about the tunnels
uh everyone heard about the tunnels and
they talk about who dug the tunnels why
they dug the tunnels where they dug the
tunnels
uh the escape route as it were they also
talk about because we've seen them
reports of the
what what happened was is the judge was
trying to figure out if they were going
to detain stuart if he was a flight risk
and um the tunnels and then unregistered
cars came up in that
in that narrative for the judge to make
her decision and she decided to detain
stewart
uh until his trial
in federal custody um well
tasha kind of gave that story and made
sure to back up that story
um and they explained that in this
interview um about the cars and the
tunnels
the other thing that they go through
which is i think very important is like
that the psychosis the psychologist dude
who who he is as a person
and how he went from being a guy who
shot out his eye
uh and wearing an eye patch
this this super villain look
this cartoonish super villain look to
ultimately back
cartoonishly
their cartoon orange mussolini jesus
right so they tell that story
the other thing that's in their
interview that i think is very
significant that i think people want to
see and watch is also the story about
the oath keepers and bundy ranch um
that's a significant story and tasha and
dakota feel like that that may have
something
to do with what happened on january 6.
so watch
watch the interview
tomorrow
tomorrow friday noon eastern 11 central
right here on the tony michaels podcast
youtube twitter twitch in the very first
hour
um we're very happy that minus touch has
partnered with this to try to get as
many eyeballs on this interview as we
possibly can
because
at gabe's right there hasn't been an
interview out there
with dakota and tasha both in the
interview um and telling their story in
long form they've done some small little
interviews asking certain questions from
the media like cnn and a few others
but nothing long form with the bolt of
them to tell their story okay let's go
back to the tweety tweets and attorney
turns am i missing anything
i think i'm in uh let's see we we we're
missing the delete facebook
um and meta story
it also looks like we haven't went to
the national prayer breakfast uh trend
as well if it's still trending let's
let's refresh here
and see if these stories are still
trending um of course delete facebook is
uh apparently
facebook stock meta
the parent company of facebook the stock
went down
um the last quarter of the year
what the [ __ ]
liam nissan says oh guys delete facebook
is trending facebook stock down 25
zuckerberg got the rona holy [ __ ] i
don't know if this thing is supposed to
oh i'm sorry i'm in the wrong one
hang on hang on let's get over here
let's get where you guys can see what
the hell i'm seeing
dude i was in the wrong tab there we go
okay
here we are this is what i'm looking at
what the hell is this
uh oh guys delete facebook is trending
zuckerberg has aruna i don't know what
if this is some kind of like healthcare
dummy that they're you know supposed to
work on
but and i don't know if this is supposed
to look like
i don't this is supposed to look like
mark zuckerberg but holy [ __ ] the
resemblance
is uncanny
whoosh
spread that around okay let's um
is there any news on this
anywhere
i hear tuck has it
this is how we do it delete facebook
facebook's uh shares plummish over more
than 20
on weak earnings um the story reads and
i'll retweet this cnbc story that tux
got here
um the the story goes is that they
didn't uh have less
revenue they had higher expenses their
expenses skyrocketed in the last quarter
and i don't know i think that's probably
due to changing the [ __ ] stupid name
from facebook to meta um i tweeted
earlier that
meta sucks sucks to suck
a name chain is coming probably i mean
they'll probably change their [ __ ]
name again
i don't know i don't get on facebook
does anyone else get on facebook i don't
get on [ __ ] facebook
i don't know does anything else do
anyone else get on facebook i don't get
on facebook i'm on instagram reluctantly
uh
i hate facebook i hate it and it's not
really a political thing for me i mean i
don't like [ __ ] mike zucker and mark
zuckerberg who does
i mean if you're a mark zuckerberg fan
jesus [ __ ] christ you need to get a
life
you really do but the thing is is
facebook is so [ __ ] clunky like
there's so much [ __ ] over there you got
the [ __ ] marketplace you got the
messenger you got this you gotta have
the instagram and then you have this
thing and you got this and it's all this
[ __ ]
i don't know it's just it's really
[ __ ] clunky to me i got a facebook
page go go to thetonymichaels.com i got
a facebook page you go over there and
follow it there ain't [ __ ] on it
i mean i don't even go over there i
ain't open the app anymore
i mean every once in a while i
accidentally click on that son of a
[ __ ] and i closed it almost immediately
[ __ ] facebook
let's see what else do we have uh
trending
um
tornado watch what is this we have crazy
crazy crazy crazy stuff going on
uh here in in the united states with
weather we know that texas
is
bracing for their power grid
waiting for it to go down because the
gqp decided that taking away women's
liberty and making sure every man woman
and child had a gun to shoot each other
was way more important than making sure
people have heat during an ice event
and apparently in texas this morning
there is ice warnings but here's a
tornado warning that's being issued for
alabama and mississippi
jesus
i mean it just it just doesn't end with
this with these weather events
it just is not going to end
um let's see if we can go find some
stuff on um
on texas
here because i think
texas has the ice event
um you know last year it was
snowmageddon was what they called it uh
and and ted cruz that [ __ ] snow
lizard
crawled his ass down to
texas let's see texas ice is that that's
our texas storms
should i search
it's the thread does anyone know what
the threat is
uh let's see
well here you go
uh sawyer here says as texas braces for
another winter storm with the broken
power grid ted cruz joking about cancun
three days ago his pack collected a
hundred thousand dollar from oil
lobbyist
which is the lobbyist that keep texas
from [ __ ] with their power grid
ted cruz here's a screenshot of it this
[ __ ] gross [ __ ] inflation out
of control gas prices are up food prices
are up lump prices the tickets to cancun
are up 32 percent
you are a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] my
friend
a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
people in texas were freezing to death
last year your dumbass takes [ __ ] you
and your family
and you know i'm not i'm not opposed to
him sending his family down to cancun
but he's he is sitting united state
senator that [ __ ] should have
stayed here and been working for the
people of texas but to expect ted cruz
to work for the people of texas ha
you're gonna wait a long [ __ ] time
for that kind of [ __ ]
a long time for ted cruz to pretend like
he's gonna work for the people of texas
and you remember when he came back with
his tail tucked between his legs he
decided he was gonna hand out water and
all kinds of [ __ ] act like he was
[ __ ] doing something after dozens of
people had died freezing to death
because republicans destroy everything
including the power grid in texas they
can't seem to muster up enough [ __ ]
courage to fix the power grid so people
in texas aren't freezing to death during
a winter event yet
yet they definitely want to make sure
that everyone in texas has a gun that
way they can shoot the ice off their
roofs or you know make sure i don't know
defend themselves from the storm i can't
[ __ ] figure this [ __ ] out
they also want to take the liberty away
from people who have uteruses
uh caitlyn points out a good point here
aoc raised four million bucks
four million bucks for the state of
texas while his dumb ass was gone
while his ass was in the airport and in
a hotel in cancun trying to decide if
it's bad optics for him to be in cancun
why people in in texas are dying
by freezing to death
the other thing too that this piece of
[ __ ] did
is left his [ __ ] dog at home
during a [ __ ] freezing event
these [ __ ] left the house and
locked the dog inside
didn't take it to like some kind of
doggy hotel
or something or a relative's house so
they could take care of it make sure
that [ __ ] dog was warm and had food
and its water bowl didn't freeze over
nope left it in the house [ __ ] snowflake
that's its name
the dog's name is snowflake
the dog's name
there's so much to unpack here even with
just the dog's name
ted cruz the snow flakiest of the
snowflake of all names his dog snowflake
and then that's the dog they leave at
home during a snow ice winter event
you really can't make this [ __ ] up like
50 60 years from now when they're
looking back on history in our timeline
that we had they're like jesus christ
you people were [ __ ] nuts
absolutely [ __ ] nuts
you really did live in reality tv
world
you just it can't it doesn't stop um
let's see if we can find some news oh
here's some news
here's a guy who would like to fix the
power grid in texas although it seems
let's look at look
let's look out for one another as this
the storm gets worse in texas we will
share info on power outages warming
centers road conditions and more in this
thread
uh please add additional info thank you
beto for um having a thread here for
people to have information
um we will
i'm going to retweet this so people see
this please get this out the people um
not just in texas but people who know
people in texas
it might be important let's listen to
what beto says here
i'm in san antonio right now where it is
a little cold and a little wet and where
we are also seeing reports of some power
outages throughout the community that
seems to be happening in other parts of
texas right now so i just wanted to
reach out and ask everyone to be safe
to go out for one another and to make
sure that we respect first responders
and local leaders as they try to protect
their communities in this thread we're
going to be posting resources like where
you can find a warming center and the
latest on power outages across the state
and ways that you can help out your
neighbors and your fellow texans right
now as the temperatures continue to drop
and as we see some icy conditions
in other parts of the state please feel
free to contribute the resources that
you know about as well and let's look
out for one another
there's a real leader right
i mean i i i i don't normally endorse
politicians and i i i it doesn't matter
because i can't vote in texas but if
you're in texas and you're gonna go
through this storm what would you rather
have would you rather have bet o'rourke
actually going out there and doing the
[ __ ] doing the work
and making sure that the govern the next
governor fixes the [ __ ] problem
tries to fix the [ __ ] problem not
just deal with the problem as it comes
up every [ __ ] year
and i think texas has a unique
opportunity here not only to secure
themselves a really good governor
but i i think texas is blue it's been
blue for a long time it's been blue
a lot of these states are blue
george's blue i think alabama
mississippi could be blue we doug jones
got elected in alabama once
if the people of texas
who know that these republicans are
destroying their state
little by little by worrying about
things like taking away people with
uterus's liberty
and making sure that every tom dick and
harry no matter who they are how old
they are what their background is has
[ __ ] weapons to make sure that they
can i don't i don't know i guess
defend themselves from the storm i can't
figure it out
but if they keep going down that road
with leaders i think they're gonna
realize that there's leaders out there
that are willing to work for texas and
do the things that texans want like you
know
have power and [ __ ]
like how in the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ] is
this even
a controversy
that we have to sit here and talk about
how a an entire party wants to not have
power in texas to own the libs
because it feels like that's what this
[ __ ] is
this backing putin asking for pardons
for [ __ ] seditious conspiracy
overturning the government [ __ ] on
the constitution
taking away people's [ __ ] liberty
twisting lies and misinformation all
around the country so more and more of
their own constituents get sick and go
to the hospital and die from covet there
are still people
dying from covid
mostly unvaccinated
the majority 90 some percent
that are listening to people who are
telling them not to get vaccinated who
were [ __ ] vaccinated
and you have leaders on the ground in
texas like beto
trying to make sure people are [ __ ]
safe doing way more than the actual
leader who's elected
i want you to go to this thread and
again if you know someone in texas share
this with them
if you're in texas share this because
this isn't about beto being a democrat
at this point
because there are probably going to be
some power outages and um people in
texas need to be safe um they're really
not
the state is not prepared for events
like this with their power grid and a
lot of people don't understand if you
don't have power how [ __ ] severe it
can be especially over an extended
period of time especially as cold as it
can get
so he's got a lot of stuff here about
frozen pipes carbon monoxide
there's a lot of good resources here
it's not it's not a republican democrat
thing it's like a hey we care about
human beings you should know this
information
and and use this information to the best
of your ability
so please go add to this thread if you
have some good information
to add to this thread share it with
people in texas if you know people in
texas share with people who may know
people in texas let's make sure that
texas even though it is run by a bunch
of gq peers
it's not everyone's fault in texas that
that is happening and we need to make
sure even if they're voting for the gq
peers
we need to make sure that they're safe
because texas unfortunately is not
prepared
for for events like this and it can be
deadly and regardless of who can die or
what can happen we need to make sure to
stand up for all americans and all
people in america not just the citizens
non-citizen citizens women children
republicans democrats
because there are people
in danger with this event veteran yoda
says there's ice covering my trees
uh caitlyn says we already have outages
we have we have people here that watch
from texas
and uh so
i hope uh i hope you're safe kaylynn
stay safe yoda stay stay if anyone else
out there in texas stay safe stay warm
um
again i i'm not saying that this thread
will save your life but it may say
someone's so
go out and share this information
and make sure make sure people
understand the risk
that texas has and and why why is so
important to elect leaders that are
pro-democracy
and
pro-democracy doesn't just like give you
all kinds of entitlements
it actually does things like make sure
that these type of events are avoided
where when when when we have global
warming and we're having big winter
events in a state like texas where
winter events should not really be
happening that often but because we have
climate change it is and it's going to
happen more and more that we have
leaders that recognize that and actually
[ __ ] do the work and and develop the
policies
and then administrate those policies to
make sure those peoples of those states
are safe
that's death
it shouldn't be about party and it's not
but the problem is there's only one
[ __ ] party willing to do that
only one the other party all they want
to do is just own the libs own them
libtards
so
if you if you want some common sense
[ __ ]
go go share this thread uh of betos
thank you beto if you're out there
listening and you're welcome on the show
anytime uh to talk i'd like i'd like to
talk to bitto and i'd like to talk to
him about what he'd like to do about
with the power grid in texas so that's
an open invitation let's see what else
do we have here oh look we have this
[ __ ] bum
beto posted this video i will keep the
lights on in texas this guy clearly
can't uh let's see what this video says
you guys have seen the video of greg
abbott promising someone i think was a
football game oh i promise we'll fix the
grid this won't happen and here we are
promise is [ __ ] broken let's listen
to this video i can guarantee the lights
will stay on
well listen
no one no one can guarantee that there
won't be a quote uh load shed event
oops
i can guarantee the lights will stay on
yep he can guarantee that the lights
will stay on
and then ah well
now that we're here and i can't
guarantee it i'm gonna have to backtrack
for just a bit
for just a bit
[ __ ]
now what's occupied democrats say
breaking republican leadership fails
again uh yet again as 70 000 texans lose
power so it uh they're reporting when
was this
do you guys know how many this was 38
minutes ago they're reporting that 70
000 texans have lost power so far
plunging them into freezing temperatures
and missed a severe weather storm uh
governor greg abbott that previously
promised the lights will stay on yep
here it is and and if you want power in
texas you should put democrats into
power because it's not really like
honestly like you can have ideological
differences like oh abortion and guns
and all this who in the [ __ ] is
diametrically opposed to the state of
texas keeping their [ __ ] power grid
open
who in the [ __ ] is opposed to that
and why the [ __ ] are you voting for
[ __ ] politicians that will do nothing
when they know the solution is right
there in front of them
they got to make up all these [ __ ]
fake ass crisis
like oh abortion and guns we got to
protect people in texas people got to
shoot people in texas because oh my god
i don't again i don't know if they want
to make sure that they have to
personally protect themselves from the
storm but guns aren't gonna do it
i i just can't figure out how we got in
this timeline
and how a governor of a state
doesn't give a [ __ ] about their power
grid
and not only that [ __ ] lies about it
yeah we'll keep the lights on don't
worry we won't turn and i won't let the
lights go out here they are 70 000
people
texans
people human [ __ ] beings can't rely
on the power grid now some people say oh
well if you can't live without the power
grid and you're not tough enough or some
[ __ ] like that look these
people who live in certain neighborhoods
certain cities they don't have the
luxury
of roughing it
they rely on the power grid they [ __ ]
pay for it
they [ __ ] pay for it's not an
entitlement they [ __ ] pay for it
so get off your [ __ ] asses and go fix
the power grid in texas
i know there's going to be a lot of
repairs currently here's the washington
post report tens of thousands of
customers in texas were without power
thursday morning as a major winter storm
continue moving east across the united
states bringing snow sleet freezing rain
to midwestern and southern states
now again here in missouri
we're having a winter event as well
but
our power grid is not in the shape that
texas is in
i mean some parts of the state it's
really shitty because republicans run in
here too
jesus
okay let's see what else um
here 42 minutes ago latest 63 000
customers plus are without power in
texas so this report is 63 000 plus
in the midst of a fierce winter storm
that has also caused 4 000 flights to be
canceled so not only not only can you
not uh get power
uh ted cruz can't get to cancun
apparently
i'm gonna tweet
cruz
won't
make
[ __ ]
sick [ __ ]
joking about cancun tickets
you piece of [ __ ] okay uh let's see what
else do we have if we have any more
reports you guys down in texas um did
you guys lose power caitlyn did you and
yoda did you guys lose power
oh it looks like caitlyn jumped off
um
yoda are you have you lost power yet you
said you had ice on your trees
um here's eugene
texas power outages map updates a winter
storm leaves thousands in darkness
so newsweek actually has the darkness
map here
yoda says you have power
okay well that's that's a good thing i'm
i'm glad that yoda's got power
i hope that you don't have to
maybe deal with it
um
we got uh we're 51 minutes into the
second hour
so we're gonna try to see if we can
track down
here's an accuweather map of the winter
storm you can see how big this storm is
um it's not like a small storm in texas
right but texas is going to see the
brunt of it because their power grid
isn't prepared
whereas most these other states are
prepared for winter storms like this
with their power grid
texas power grid was not designed to
handle
storms
like this
because when they designed it
uh climate had not changed as much as it
is now
but we see it it goes all the way down
to the austin area
the blue
what's the blue let's see
and looking for a key here
i'm i'm guessing that's um sleet snow or
ice
uh accuweather says winter storm
warnings cover
a consecutive path all the way from
texas to the main canadian border that
is a big [ __ ] storm
so please people in texas stay safe
i'm very important
see if we can find
some more news it looks like seventy
thousand is the number right now
i don't know if they've gotten more
power back on
uh yeah yoda you're right um you know
the opposite isn't is true in washington
state
where they had 115 degree temperatures
this summer
and their grid isn't designed for that
type of climate change so it's on both
ends of the spectrum
the good news is in washington they
actually have some politicians that are
willing to do some [ __ ]
here's another national map colin has it
here
we can literally drive from central
texas to eastern maine and never leave
the winter storm warning holy [ __ ]
that's a
that is a
unreal observation
i don't know if it's been a long time
since we probably had a storm at this
massive size
um
[Music]
see if we can get some
i want to see if there's some video
of this storm there's a lot of pictures
here in this thread i'm in the texas
storm thread oh jesus christ
the icicles
good lord
uh
[Music]
fifty thousand seventy thousand uh yoda
are you watching the local news down
there is there um
is your reports of power coming back on
are they just doing uh is it rolling
blackouts is it because of ice what um
what's happening um in the way of why
these power outages are happening
is it because they they just don't have
enough power to distribute
are they saying um that's what i'm
trying to look for here
i don't know if someone's got a link you
can drop it to me
we're 54 minutes into the hour
let's just search texas
uh yoda says as far as i know it's down
lines so it sounds like ice is taking
the power lines down which is causing
the loss of power of approximately 70
000 texans it sounds like that's what
you're um understanding
let's see
looking for some news here if they can
give us more reports
but it's looking like that's
that's the number for now so
stay safe in texas please stay safe
um
don't think that you're too tough for
the cold
um if you do lose power for an extended
period of time make sure you are safe
and again visit this thread
let's see here's the thread
that better
posted it's got a lot of resources in
here like the power outages uh where
your warming centers are if you lose
power for too long um also what to do
about your freezing pipes and carbon
monoxide
that is a a big risk so make sure make
sure you're you're
following all those instructions
um
please say stay
safe in texas
um take it seriously uh it is a thing
that can cause
death so please stay safe
i want i want to bring up again
before we go that we do have the
interview with uh tasha adams and dakota
adams
tomorrow morning
at noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
we will have the interview
with them uh tomorrow
and we will we will be
uh talking uh in the first hour with
them so the interview will play the
first hour it's about an hour and 15
minutes and then we're going to do bone
end of the week the second hour so stay
tuned tomorrow
the link is already on youtube and the
link is also on that clip that minus
touch posted we'll be posting it we'll
try to be spreading it around on twitter
today so that you guys have the link for
tomorrow so come join us live tomorrow
noon eastern 11 central for the
interview
with uh tasha adams and dakota adams the
ex-wife and son of stuart rhodes the
founder of the oak keeper who is was
deposed yesterday by the january 6th
select committee and is being detained
right now in oklahoma gonna be
transferred to washington dc
um he was he was uh rejected for his
request to stay there uh for his
role and in his indictment
in a seditious conspiracy to overturn
the government of the united states
during the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt
i think it will be very interesting
maybe there'll be some news over the
next over the next coming weeks
about maybe what stewart had disclosed
to the january 6 select committee you
know they pushed back the public
hearings and i think it's because of
depositions like this
uh depositions from people like stewart
rhodes and the people inside the
conspiracy to overturn the the
constitution of the united states and
participate in the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup attempt
the violent the attempt of the violent
overthrow of the government of the
united states
i think it's very important that they
collect all the evidence to make sure
that when us the american people see the
story out in the open and in public
during these public hearings that they
have all the information to give us and
they have the story to lay out in front
of us because i believe that's what the
january 6th select committee is going to
do for us and what the department of
justice is going to do is just what
they're doing with stuart rhodes and
over the over 700 other defendants
that have participated in january 6th
and also the indictments to come
i would imagine that we're probably
going to get to a thousand indictments
at some point they're i think they're
around hovering around 750 indictments
in total
and i think we're going to get to almost
a thousand indictments by the time this
whole thing is done um and i don't know
but it really does seem like if there's
a conspiracy for sedition and the former
president of the united states is
standing on stage promising pardons to
people who could flip on him and flip on
members of congress and also promising
pardons like he did mike flynn steve
bannon roger stone and paul manafort
those [ __ ] treasonous [ __ ]
he gave them pardons he's he's
projecting
don't tell on me and i'll pardon you
which he had the chance to pardon him
don't you find that the funniest part
stuart rhodes could have received a
pardon
why not i mean trump didn't do anything
that was [ __ ] normal in the first
place why wouldn't trump issue a pardon
for all the people who participated in
january 6. bucky could have wrote it on
a mcdonald's napkin before he left
office
in his true style in fashion took a
sharpie wrote the pardon out on a
mcdonald's a greasy ass mcdonald's
napkin
and said i pardoned all the people who
tried to overthrow the government for me
he could have done that
why not he's staying on stage saying now
trying to incite him into violence to
make sure that if he gets arrested that
somehow there's violence in the name of
him
that's what he's doing
but he's trying to keep their mouth shut
because he's scared he's scared at what
they'll say so tomorrow
tasha adams and dakota adams are not
scared of they are not scared to say
what they want to say and tell their
story about stewart rhodes about the
oath keepers there's going to be a lot
of surprises in there we talk about the
eye patch we talk about how he got his
eyes shut up we talk we talk about the
bundy ranch how that the significance of
january 6 with what happened with the
oath keepers at bundy ranch we talk
about surprises of the oath keepers are
they white supremacists are they not
you will you will be surprised by the
answer that they give i'm telling you
have to come tomorrow you have to see
this
so go follow us go follow us and
subscribe on on youtube right now set
the bell notification the link is there
on the channel also go follow us on
twitter uh at tonymichaelspod at the
tony michaels and i am gabe sanchez
we'll be posting this link all over
twitter today
for the episode
tomorrow morning on youtube twitter
twitch live
noon eastern 11 central with stewart
rhodes ex-wife tasha adams and tasha's
son dakota they break it down who
stewart rhodes is and and they really i
think they make a good case of
why he did what he did until
until tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking